他人品、
责任心，
爱你，
尊敬你，
能够体会女性的生育之苦，
能够体会你带孩子的不容易，
这些东西都比长相重要，
我想请你帮我对于我的感情和工作做一些指导的。
说说你的情况啊，
不是，
今年24岁，
家里是三个孩子的，
是老大，
我爸我妈呢，
年纪都是在50岁左右，
在广东这边做一家加工厂，
他们是有社保的，
我们一家人就是那种很本分，
老老实实吃苦的打工人。
先说感情，
有第一个男孩儿是我，
现在和他是属于是恋爱关系，
我们在一起有三四年的时间，
比他大了三岁，
他的工作就是穿绿色衣服的，
我们家离他们家距离有60km，
我爸妈不同意我跟他，
和他在一起，
首先这个距离是他们觉得有点远，
开车要一个小时左右，
还有一个是他的家庭情况，
他爸妈是属于离婚状态，
第二个男孩老家相亲介绍的，
在老家稳定的工作，
家里也是那种很本分很老实的打工人，
但是他长相可能外表我不喜欢，
但是人很聪明，
我就感觉选择好难，
一个是喜欢的，
一个是合适的，
再说说他你跟他俩相处的细节呗，
我就感觉可能是第一个，
因为我们第一个是自己谈的，
可能觉得我喜欢他，
可。
多一些，
他也没有为了要娶你做过什么努力，
比如你爸爸妈妈不同意这件事情，
他也没有说能够有胆量到你的爸爸妈妈面前去争取什么，
去求取你，
也没有这个行为和动作，
是不是他可能有这个想法，
但是他觉得我妈妈肯定会拒绝，
比如说我要给他讲起来，
我说以后我们要结婚啊，
怎么怎么样，
他会觉得结婚以后要面临房子啊，
彩礼那些，
很要房钱，
他就觉得我不想谈这个事情，
这也是我有点犹豫的原因，
那就是他没有为你去争取，
没有为你去抗争，
就算说你的爸爸妈妈表现出来说不同意的话，
他也就算了，
他就说你或许给你的爸妈妈好好说一下或者怎么样，
但是我感觉他除了什么就长得好看，
我很喜欢他，
但是其他的我确实没有底气，
其实说白了，
人家并没有说非我不可，
并没有说要为了跟我在一起，
要去做什么努力，
做什么牺牲，
做什么付出，
没有，
那你上赶着干什么？
他也觉得他现在每天都在很努力的工作啊，
也是为了以后可能生活过好一点，
这样子他努力工作不是为了你，
那是为了他自己，
我知道他才21岁，
对对，
是的，
你多大啊，
我24岁，
所以我就很内耗，
很纠结，
但是我真的很喜欢他，
就就这一点点喜欢他，
但是他不想为跟你结婚这件事情做努力，
做付出。
那咱也不能绑着他吧，
他觉得他那种家庭情况，
他子已经很努力的生活了，
下一个吧，
人家也没想跟你结婚，
上赶着干什么姐妹，
他就觉得说可能结婚是一个非常大的事情，
现在他的能力还完全承担不了，
那不就等于我不想跟你结婚吗？
听不明白人家的言下之意吗？
听不明白人家的潜台词吗？
可能是这样，
我也觉得，
所以我很犹豫，
你，
你无爱，
赶紧下一个，
我还觉得他妈妈爸爸的以后养老问题啊，
这些我都要考虑一下，
我就觉得压力很大，
就包括我妈妈他们不同意的是，
我们这个经济情况是不允许找月嫂啊，
保姆那种，
他是说以后可能有个男孩妈妈能够比如说去生宝宝啊，
能够照顾你一些，
妈妈就不同意这一点，
他说他们那样子肯定是，
如果结了婚之后是你自己生活，
肯定上班呀，
生活都要靠你自己，
就是很难，
反正第一个肯定成不了，
人家第一二十一岁，
第二没有那么上杆子的，
想娶你，
咱就看第二个，
要是能处处不能处的话，
赶紧找第二个工作挺稳定的，
也是有一点，
可能他长得没第一个好看，
好看这个事儿吧，
实话说啊，
像我们这种结过婚的，
或者说这种三四十岁的女人来看的话，
长相在婚姻里面其实是最不值钱的，
是真的长相不值钱，
我知道我家里人也是这样说她人品责任。
心爱你，
尊敬你，
能够体会女性的生育之苦，
能够体会你带孩子的不容易，
这些东西都比长相重要，
包括说性格幽默，
很大度，
不小家子气，
不偏执，
能够化解夫妻之间的矛盾，
都比长相重要。
这两个目前接触的来说都挺好的，
就没有那种过不去的缺点，
比如说偏执啊，
都挺好，
那就跟第二个再接触接触呗，
第一个肯定是不行啊，
人家第一年轻，
第二没有那么上杆子，
并不想着要结婚，
你这第一个我觉得他还是更么多的，
结婚就是家琪的原因，
一般好，
那别的还有什么问题吗？
这工作的事情就实我爸和我叔叔他们在这边就开始加工厂嘛，
就在我收务室里上班，
我就感觉每天就很多事情我都干不完，
但是我又不知道怎么跟他们说，
我，
我如果跟他说，
我说这件事情太多了，
我干不完的话，
他们可能就觉得啊，
小年纪就没有上进心半年，
现在做的工也不是我喜欢的内容，
但是我又实在找不到自己喜欢啥，
找不到自己喜欢啥，
能养活自己就先干着，
你真的干不完吗？
我现在啊，
年轻人8小时工作的话，
可能只有一个半小时在干工作，
剩下的6个半小时在刷抖音，
刷直播，
刷各种剧，
你是真干不完还是假干不完都有，
因为是干不完就想拖，
越拖越干不完，
一拖就不想干，
一刷抖音就接着干。
如果你还没有找到其他的谋生的本领的话，
好好珍惜现在这份工作吧，
你看看现在的失业率，
看看现在的大学生的就业率吧。
是的，
我很紧巴，
很拖延，
就很焦虑的，
平时的状态是这样的，
姑娘，
比如说21岁那个小伙子，
他为什么没有那么着急说想要跟你定下来，
他觉得他能找到更好的，
不是我觉得沈阳是他，
因为可能这是经济压力，
这是真的，
这不是我恋爱了，
这是真的。
姑娘，
你必须要把自己活成一个，
嗯，
是生命力中心，
影响力中心，
幸福的中心，
能力的中心，
价值的中心，
别人才有可能为你赴汤蹈火，
明白吗？
你现在比如说你这个工作，
你觉得干的没有价值，
你自己都觉得你干的没有价值，
别人怎么会觉得你有价值啊？
是啊，
要么你就好好的干这份工作，
干成不可或缺，
干出自己的价值对不对？
明白了，
好，
就这样啊，
OK,
谢谢，
看不到记得点赞关注哦。